Hey look guys my name is China welcome
back to my game and in the series so
last time we talked about what exactly a
game engine was make sure you check out
that video if you haven't already and
before we begin I just want to give a
huge thank you to all of the patrons
that make this series possible
you guys aren't supporting this series
you can do so by going to patron up on
4/2 Cherno to get access to these videos
like a week early as well as plenty of
other cool rewards such as being
involved in the planning process of
these videos and finding out information
about where this is going and actually
influencing whether series goes as well
so huge thank you to all the people
involved in that so today what we're
going to talk about what I thought we
would talk about is actually just kind
of going through some of the different
things that are going to go into this
game engine because we actually do need
to plan what we're going to be doing
right I've even got a little bit of a
notepad here that I'm going to draw
stuff on so that can kind of really
explain to you guys where this series
are going to go what we're going to do
over the next few videos and how I'm
going to actually structure all of this
and what does this even look like so to
build a game engine first of all first
and foremost is not an easy task right
it's actually quite difficult to build a
game engine because if you take a look
at just game engines kind of in the wild
or game studios and how they kind of
relate with game engines you know that
everyone except the largest of teams
really usually goes with an already made
game engine and if a team does decide to
build their own game engine it usually
requires a lot of resources which is why
it's not the best idea to kind of choose
to kind of write your own game engine if
all you want to do is make a game
because there are other resources out
there there's no real reason for you to
actually do everything yourself
that being said because we're not a
massive team and because it's really
only just me I mean I really want you
guys to contribute but obviously
understandably I don't think that Israel
is túcume to depend on consistent
contributors you know who aren't
professional engineers who I'm paying so
because that whole thing doesn't exist
it's really up to me to build this thing
and direct this thing so I have to be
reasonable with my story I can't say
that we've been built unreal I can't say
we can build unity or anything like that
that's just completely crazy right and
I'm here to actually try and make a game
engine that will exist maybe you know
within the lifetime of the viewers who
are watching this series so because of
that is a bunch of compromises that I
have to make and what I kind of take
this slowly and kind of well by take
this slowly I mean we're going to end up
iterating quite rapidly over certain
features and what I mean by that is
we're going to focus on building up the
minimal groundwork we need to actually
get something working and then we'll
iterate over it and improve it and add
more features and have more stability
and more performance and optimization
and do things like that
we're not going to try and write perfect
100% complete and powerful extensible
code from the beginning because that
would take us like a year to actually
get to the point where we have an
application stack like on a window and
all of that because you know we'd have
to do it so perfectly we're gonna can I
cut that out we're gonna rapidly go over
this stuff and I'll just you know
probably end up just improving code over
time as well as you guys will contribute
and help with that as well so it's kind
of a basic idea of how the series is
gonna run the compromises that I'm
making we can get into probably when we
get to them I don't want to kind of
spend today talking about you know along
the entire platform of what the game
engine is this is the stuff that I'm not
going to have because if we start
talking about that now it's going to
take a while and it probably isn't going
to interest to many people but I mean
things like having like a level editor
like the level editor is going to be
built into the game engine it's going to
exist in the game engine runtime I'm not
going to go ahead and build an entire
stay sharp WPF application that has its
own kind of you know it's a full
standalone like Windows application that
just links in with the game engine and
another live stuff because that's just
that's just on the face of what's gonna
take way too long it would be the kind
of my recommendation for if you had a
huge team I would probably do that right
but because we don't have that we're
going to just end up kind of building a
level editor out of like I am GUI or
something like that
within the game and in itself and then
that way
be all kind of sable floss and it won't
be the best solution but it will be
something that is achievable by us
that's an example right shade a
compilation is another example like we
could like ideally we'd write our own
shader language and then have that
compile to like you know metals method
to metals shader language to like you
know GLSL to hlsl to all these kind of
shader languages based on the platform
that you're on and that would be an
amazing system that would probably take
a year or two to build right so by one
person so it's not something we're like
we have to make compromises along the
way and I just want all of you to be
aware that even though I really want to
build an amazing engine this series I
let you like during I guess this series
is to build an amazing engine I have to
be realistic with what we were able to
achieve now that being said there's no
reason why you can't go back and then
later add those features right it's just
that when I'm talking about what the
core technology that we're building will
will entail like I have been quiet
brutal maybe with kind of some of the
compromises that we're going to be
making because you have to remember that
apart from the fact that I'm one person
building a game engine I'm also I also
have a full-time job building game
engines for EA and also not only that
but I'm not just building an engine in
my spare time I'm teaching everything
that goes into it I'm planning I'm doing
all this kind of stuff so because of
that it kind of ends up you know not
being as efficient obviously if I just
sat down for like you know tiles a week
or like two hours a week and actually
wrote code because if I did that I'd
have an engine in no time since I have
to teach all of this it obviously does
take its toll in terms of time and
efficiency anyway enough about let's
actually dive in and take a look at what
a game and it actually has what we're
going to do and like basically plan out
our roadmap for the next few videos and
this series now with planning's
I am going to have a major kind of
design episode probably before I begin a
massive new feature for example before
we start building the renderer we're
going to plan out exactly how the API is
going to look for that look for yeah so
what the API for that is going to look
like how we're going to actually build
that thing
and just the semantics of how
everything's going to work so let's dive
down and take a look at in the next few
videos okay so I really do want to kind
of provide some kind of overview as to
what our game engine which by the way
does not have a name at the moment as of
me recording this video maybe out maybe
I would have come up with one by the
time everyone sees this but I don't have
a name for this engine right now so if
you have a name suggestion drop it in
the comments below because I'm gonna
have to make a github repository pretty
soon and that needs a name obviously so
if you have any name suggestions for the
game engine just drop a comment below
and hopefully we'll come up with
something pretty cool okay so game
engines right um let's start off by just
kind of talking about exactly what goes
into them so the first point I want to
kind of make is that we need like an
entry point and an engine should provide
some kind of entry point now an entry
point is essentially when we launched
our application or our game that's been
made with this engine what happens right
this is something that a lot of people
overlook like they don't really they
think okay well you've got your main
function and you're done
well yeah but like what happens with
that like what controls where the main
function is what controls the code it
gets executed with the main function is
that something the client controls of
the game controls or is it something
that the engine actually controls and
maybe we kind of implement by either a
macro or it gets imported somehow what
happens with that when we if we break
this down to primitive building blocks
when we launch our game or when we
launch our engine what happens right
what controls what happens that's what
the entry point is all about once we
kind of dealt with that we have
something called the application layout
or at least that's kind of what I call
it and the application layout is just
really a section of our code that deals
with application kind of life cycle and
events and stuff like that so for
example our run loop right what keeps
the application opening and rendering
frames right what keeps the time going
forward what execute all of the code
that our game wants to execute what
about events what about things like
windows being resized or like closed or
input event
like mouse and keyboard right all of
this kind of stuff is dealt with in the
application land we need a way to
basically run our game or runner running
our engine as an actual application on
whatever platform it's going to be on
that's what the application layer kind
of fits in from that I kind of want to
go into the window layout now this is
kind of a interesting part of the engine
because if you think about a window
really a window is only something that
exists on desktop platforms like Windows
Mac Linux they have windows and as you
kind of if you've done done any kind of
programming before if you look at
something like the OpenGL series that I
have on my channel as well you know we
create a window that's kind of one of
the first things we do in our actual
application we create a window because
that's going to be the target for all of
our graphics rendering as well as you
know where kind of input events are
gonna come from this is our entire
application is that window right one of
the platforms like mobile platforms it's
a little bit different it's more or less
kind of like a surface because the app
that you've kind of given an app prompt
and creating an app and console
platforms kind of similar as well so I'm
really kind of talking about desktop
platforms when I deal with window layout
stuff but because we are primarily going
to be targeting desktop to begin with
and we'll talk a little bit more about
platform support and rendering API
support and all that stuff later in this
video
but because we're gonna be primarily
dealing with that we're gonna have a
window layout and and inside that window
layout we need to deal with things like
input and events so input kind of gets
put into events so our event manager
will handle inputs what we'll handle
input events that get kind of picked up
by our window and our application now
event managers are kind of a really
important thing as well we're gonna
build one that kind of funk functions on
a very basic kind of messaging and
broadcast system which basically just
means that certain kind of layers in our
application can subscribe to events and
get notified when events happen by the
kind of application layer stack when
that happens events will get propagated
to those layers and the layers can kind
of choose if they want to propagate them
to things like the exponent system which
will also
so that's kind of how events will work
it's just basically a messaging system
where we get interrupted when it event
happened or rather not really
interrupted but when an event happens we
get notified because our kind of on
event function essentially gets called
however there's two parts to this
because with input events for example
yes it's really good to be notified when
a case press but also sometimes we want
to tip we want to check the state of an
actual input device so for example where
is the current Mouse position is this
spacebar currently pressed right these
those aren't kind of a messaging system
in tomorrow less us asking the
application hey is this state the case
right and if so what to do something
there's kind of two parts to that which
again we'll discuss when we plan out the
events and kind of input system from
there the renderer is probably one of
the biggest systems that we actually
have to deal with now the renderer is
what actually renders graphics on our
screen
we basically tell the renderer usually
once the frame hey it's time for you to
kind of go through your list of things
that you need to draw on the screen and
actually draw them right by far this is
going to be the biggest system at the
engine and the most complicated now I
don't want to go ahead and say that the
renderer is what basically the engineers
because a lot of game engine series or
like when people teach game engine
programming they always start with the
renderer there was focus on the renderer
and the renderer is just this huge thing
that gets kind of built immediately
right and I can't really argue with that
because the problem is like most likely
when you're building a game the very
first thing you want to see are colored
pixels on the screen right you want to
see graphics so of course it's going to
be a good idea to kind of get that as
soon as possible and for me planning
this theory is this was this was a
really kind of long like discussion I
essentially had with myself and others
about whether or not I should start with
graphics or whether or not I should
maybe get a lot of stuff done and the
way that we're going to kind of order
this stuff is we're not actually going
to get the graphics immediately we are
going to pretty quickly have like a
basic debugging layer up and you know
just the ability to basically just
texts and maybe some other GUI kind of
elements on the screen in kind of an
application case but we're not going to
go ahead and build a 3d renderer in the
first like a few months probably of this
series that's just not gonna happen the
reason that's not gonna happen is
because festival a game engine is much
more than just a 3d renderer right so
there's no need for us to kind of rush
into that but also you're gonna see how
much easier it's going to be to actually
build a proper 3d renderer when we have
all of the other systems kind of already
operational it's just going to be an
absolute breeze compared to what it
would be if we have basically a raw
bare-bones application and we started
writing like OpenGL code or DirectX code
or whatever immediately that's just
that's not a good long-term strategy and
we want to obviously take kind of the
longest time strategy because we're
trying to actually build an engine the
renderer you know once we have all that
this by the way isn't necessarily a list
that's in order so don't think that you
know we're gonna do the entry point
first an application like win or later
this is just kind of all the stuff
that's kind of going into this so once
we have the renderer I keep saying once
we have the renderer as if it is ordered
but we basically need some kind of
render I'll say render API abstraction
which basically just means that we're
going to support multiple rendering
api's through our engine now to begin
with we're just going to deal with
OpenGL the reason I've chosen are from
GL at the beginning is because I already
have an OpenGL stories that people can
refer to and also because to be quite
honest it is the simplest API out there
and it's cross platform meaning that if
we decide to have our code run on the
Mac and Linux which I would like to get
running pretty early on in this series
OpenGL is gonna work out of the box if
we went with something like DirectX
which might have actually been mining my
first choice you know it would be first
of all more complicated to begin with
and I would have to spend more time
teaching actual DirectX than writing the
code so they don't have a dedicated
series for it and because it is more
complicated than ours in jail instead of
doing all that apart from doing all that
I will also need to as soon as we have
Michael
because I have to implement another
rendering API but because our engine
will support multiple rendering API is
eventually like Vulcan metal DirectX
OpenGL all that kind of stuff
is important to kind of design the
renderer in a way with the API that
you're actually using is abstract 'add
meaning that when we decide to add an
additional render API it's not going to
be this whole nightmare rewrite because
what we've already said everything up to
be pretty much API agnostic obviously
some things are going to have to be a
yet specific it's not like we can just
write a function called upload texture
and then that then implement that four
times for each API because the way that
we want to create a renderer would be
different based on the API because
Vulcan might be a little bit more
efficient at doing certain things if you
do it this way versus like the OpenGL
way so we kind of do still need to write
two code paths not just like every
function that OpenGL has let's create a
copy of it and then that's not going to
work right I mean anyone who's done kind
of multiple API programming will
obviously know that that is the case but
we are going to design the render off
from the ground up in an abstraction in
an abstract kind of way so that we can
deal with that I'm gonna summarize this
entire section by saying basically
debugging and support now this doesn't
necessarily mean debugging as in I'm
trying to fix my code but just really if
you take the debug word out of that and
you think about that what does it mean
to add debugging support to your engine
or to an application basically M is
talking about essentially building a
building with scaffolding around it
right when we construct any kind of
application we need good ways to
actually see what's going on and debug
it and solve our problems and build
something so it's something like a
logging system right that's something
that might be really simple but it's
just something that we need to have and
we need to have it so that we can log
any kind of data types that we have
really easily and with a little bit to
files and all that stuff what about
performance right we've written our
renderer found
nasty but it's a little bit slow well
where's all the time being spent well in
order to work that out we need some kind
of profiling system right we want to be
able to basically have our application
potentially run in the special mode that
is outside of like visual studio
settings like we want our application to
actually do it itself so that we can run
it on any platform and not have to worry
about you know using certain tools that
are available on certain platforms you
know we want to essentially instrument
the code which means we want to put code
into our code that only runs in like
debug mode or something like that which
Bay three times every function and says
and then you know collects it into like
a nice kind of view so that maybe then
we can use some kind of tool to actually
look at that and see okay pull in my
render function I can see the text route
putting on the uniform binding is taking
up the most time maybe I've written that
Foley maybe I need to optimize that
right that's a good that's something
that's so important to have that people
just kind of don't think about because
of course if you're writing a simple
application you might not care about
that stuff but since we're adding
something serious here we want to have
all these systems available to us
because they'll help us a lot out in the
future I'm gonna kind of accelerate
through this a little bit because I feel
like this is videos dragging on and as
we come to other features we'll deal
with them but stuff like scripting you
know we want to have like Lua or some
kind of lead to c-sharp and - I don't
really care at this point I haven't
decided but want to have a scripting
language kind of built in so that
instead of kind of dealing with dealing
with C++ code all the time
we can actually write scripts and much
higher level languages that even like
artists or content creators can write
easily without having to think about
stuff like memory speaking of memory we
obviously want memory systems
I mean custom allocators and memory
tracking because our memory systems
because memory is a huge deal for
performance and also a resource that we
really do need to manage well and when
it comes time for debug certain things
as well memory usage and perhaps even
like CPU time spent on memory allocation
is something that we obviously want to
kind of be able to inspect and minimize
as much as possible
an entity converting system or kind of
an ECS is as well
think that we need to have an opponent's
system which isn't ECS this is just a
way for us to be able to kind of create
game objects in the world and then kind
of modularize them like be able to kind
of include certain components include
certain systems - each kind of
individual and see your game object we
have in our world so they've been kind
of define its behavior and what actually
the engine deals with in the first
episode I talked about the fact that
game engines are really just Datuk
transformation machines where basically
we just taking data and then the engine
does something with them well this kind
of entity component system is a way for
us to say I have this object in my world
I want you to draw it as I want you to
draw it this 3d model at its position
right at its transform I want this
script to be attached to it so that it
can bounce around the room or something
I want you know I want it to have kind
of a physics material so that it can
actually interact with physics and all
that stuff I want it to play this audio
you can't get a point right it's just a
way for us to be able to define what
actually the engine does with an entity
that we have right when we launch into a
world or a scene or a level or something
like that we want to be able to load in
all of our objects and then say well
what actually happens to them how do
they work you know what is the engine
supposed to do with all this data that's
coming in and that's kind of essentially
what an ACF is speaking of physics we
want some kind of physics solution will
tell what that probably a lot later on I
think that's about it I mean well you
know obviously there's like file i/o and
stuff like that and also like a VF s
which is a virtual file system that we
also want to talk about later and design
I think that's about it I mean you know
obviously we'll kind of have a build
system as well and custom asset types so
if we have a 3d model or a texture we
have like 3d model or 3d models or
textures that get authored by content
creators we want to be able to convert
them into a custom format that our
engine that is optimized for our engine
so that we don't have to waste waste
time transforming that data into our
data at
long time so we can kind of do that
offline put into that by building our
asset offline and then it's really just
really simple and easy to actually kind
of just boot up our game and
everything's in the right format and
everything is the best so we definitely
need that um as well as what was the
other thing I was going to mention with
that yeah hot-swappable assets right so
we want to be able to you know change
you know modern we want to have
Photoshop open we want to be able to
kind of draw something on our texture in
Photoshop here ctrl s we want our build
system to pick that up and build it and
then reload that into our game while
it's all running in real time so that we
can kind of update stuff even like a 3d
model we can just kind of tweak some of
the vertices or you know modify it in
some way and it should just ha swap
right into our engine so the we can kind
of make changes to it while the game is
running that's not a really important
system but again probably isn't really
that worth talking about right now
but it's just something some of the
stuff that's kind of I'm planning to
actually go into this whole kind of
engine and project of a building anyway
looking at the list I think that's about
it I haven't covered any specifics just
kind of high level systems the way that
this series is going to go is next time
we're just going to start a project as
you know I am a full-time software
engineer today so I don't have a billion
years to make this series so the best
way for me to actually do this is we're
just gonna start writing code I'm gonna
start explaining it and wherever there's
wherever I write code that warrants a
specific explanation I might just make a
video where I kind of draw diagrams and
talk about it in one detail after it's
actually being done but the point is
that the best way to actually write this
massive engine and this overwhelming
amount of work is to actually start
writing it instead of spend a billion
years talking about it that being said
the code that I write will mostly be
live I will have already written when we
get to more complicated systems like
logging for example I've already got I
will have already have had kind of a
logging solution ready to go that I will
essentially just kind of write for you
and explain how it works right and that
kind of code it will be available on a
development branch to patrons ahead way
ahead of time so
that's a really good kind of thing for
me to do because that means that since
it is available to patrons those people
can kind of read through it help me out
point out some flaws maybe say that all
this is way too hard to use you know
maybe you can simplify the API or
something like that and we can find
iterate over that before it actually
makes it into production and into these
videos which is another reason why I
really need your support so that's kind
of exciting and that's kind of the way
the series and I go so next time we're
going to make a project talking a little
bit about the constraints of this series
I guess or kind of the way that this is
going for now we're just going to
support Windows only and we're just
going to spawn up in jail only I will
write all the code with other platforms
in mind meaning I'm not going to just
write everything you know like my
application dot CPP file is not going to
contain a Windows code in it like win32
API code in it right because obviously
the engines going to support other
platforms in the future so I am still
going to abstract things and make sure
that I actually divide on your platform
specific code or render a key a specific
code to its own kind of files that will
not be compiled on other platforms or if
we're compiling for other or rendering
API is that battle is going to be taken
care of don't worry but for now we're
just making the assumption that this is
Windows only and we're going to be only
dealing with OpenGL okay that's gonna
basically hurry this up so that we can
actually have an actual product an
actual project like a an actual thing in
our hands before we actually go ahead
and start moving on to more complicated
things because right iterating over this
is by [ __ ] me the best way to
actually have this done so we're also
not gonna deal with like kind of pack
like build systems or you know like say
may for anything of that at all for now
because that's gonna be that's just not
really necessary once we do start
talking about other platforms whenever
that might be we'll deal with those
things when we actually get there and I
hope you guys enjoy this video if you
did you can hit the like button you can
all support the stories by going to
patron
that the channel this is such a huge
like series I mean even me talking about
it right now I didn't script this video
or anything I just had a few nights off
to the side I like this is like the by
far the biggest project I've ever done
in my life I'm going to need so much
help from you guys but it's such an
exciting thing I don't think anyone
needs to actually done something this
detailed and this kind of highly
produced I guess quality wise so I'm
really looking forward to being able to
do this for you guys as always you can
help support me by going into that
linked pattern I hope for such the
channel I can't wait to see you guys the
next episode where we actually start
writing for it see you guys later
goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]